let's have a go okay now a lot of you
have i've tried to graph this and you've
gone back to method one
there's nothing wrong with method one
it's great it works that's why i taught
it to you okay
however i want you to know both part of
the reason why
is just like in real life when you've
got like two different tools to choose
from right
sometimes one is better than the other
depending on the situation okay
so that's why i want you to be able to
master both of them so you were like
sometimes i'll see i'll use this one and
sometimes you get the idea
alright so let's go where i'm going to
start with
is the y-intercept that's the because
i've already prepared
i'll define the y-intercept and plot it
okay where's the y-intercept i think
most people got this
it's negative 3 right negative three
okay so you go to your graph
and you go there's zero i'll show you
you go down one two three there's
negative three
okay now this point's important so i'm
going to go through there so i mark it
with a big x
okay right i've found the y intercept
and plotted it
now i have to find the x intercept by
making y equals zero and this is the
step where
method two and method one are different
and that's where people struggle a
little bit so
you go back to here and you make y
equals zero right in fact the um
the fancy way and if you want to if
you're serious about your setting out
you're going to you're next to that kind
of thing
the proper way to set this out is to say
let
y equal zero okay so that's that's a
fantastic saying well i'm going to see
what happens when y is zero i'm gonna
make it work
okay but let let's the fancy word for it
okay so i'm gonna put in
zero everywhere i see y looks like this
okay now at this point
um i want to get x by itself right you
can do a couple of things
uh probably i don't like fractions i
just like fractions i'm a bit
bit discriminatory like that so in order
to get rid of the fraction
what should i do what should i multiply
by to get rid of a half
if i multiply by a half it will become
even more of a fraction i'll get a
quarter
okay all right i should i'm multiplying
by
i could divide by a half which is the
same as multiplying by two
all right so that's what's gonna happen
okay there you go
so i've multiplied everything by two
zero by two gives you zero
a half by two gives you one three by two
gives you
six okay now i need to do one more thing
i want to get x by itself
so i move the six over the other side
okay are you happy with that so six
is my x-intercept that's my x-intercept
okay now in fact i don't think my graph
is actually big enough to fit six on
this i'm going to make it a bit longer
and if yours is the same that's okay
just go further
so you get the shape right okay so six i
go
one two three four five
six there it is
so there are my two points okay and
these are what i can join up
i missed last time so this time i will
use a ruler
there you go i think you miss again
well fingers fingers crossed
so there's the graph of y equals a half
x minus three and i might label it as
such those